a lot of people have positioned this
debate as you know just a battle between
the tech industry and the content
industry and it's an insider's game it's
a bunch of rich guys playing you know
around with each other I don't think
that's the case I think what we're
talking about is the freedom to innovate
that's a very profound and important
thing first of all all of the services
that that consumers across the web have
come to know and love you know their 800
million people using Facebook the future
of those services is at risk and so your
use of the internet is threatened by
this legislation if the legislation
passes it'll mean that you will pay more
for a lot of the things that you've come
to appreciate and that have been much
much less expensive beyond that there's
innovation and there's the the pace of
innovation slowing down the next
Facebook the next novel service that
consumers would get really excited about
is is not going to happen you know today
one of the reasons the Internet has
produced such wonderful innovation is
that it's been very inexpensive to start
a company foursquare got 200,000 users
on $25,000 that's unheard of in an era
before the open source software that
everybody uses to build on top of and
the distribution platform called the
internet which the end users pay for you
know we all buy our access to the
internet ourselves and so no no no
supplier of content has to buy the
access the way they used to in the cable
world and so by lowering the cost of
creating new new services we've
dramatically increased the amount of
innovation the problem is you know
foursquare is essentially started with
three people and they were able to get
to 100,000 users with five or six people
now we're going to have three people and
a lawyer involved in all these startups
because as an investor we're going to be
looking at these and the first due
diligence question you're going to ask
is you are you clean is there any risk
associated with liability you know could
one of these people come after you could
the Attorney General come after you what
are you doing that might infringe and
the definitions in this legislation are
so vague that there
how hard they try they're not going to
be able to give crisp answers to that so
it creates a huge amount of uncertainty
which will chill investment which will
chill innovation the real irony here is
if you had to pick the content
industries least favorite company it'd
probably be googled what's happening
here is that Google has about 200
lawyers on staff today it's not going to
affect them at all they'll fight these
guys they have the money they have the
lawyers they'll just you know create a
team and go fight these guys but if you
take a little search engine startup like
DuckDuckGo which hopes to compete with
google which is innovating in novel ways
and creating a new experience for
consumers they have three people if the
fourth one has to be a lawyer they're
never going to get there and the last
thing is to come back to this notion of
the freedom to innovate and why is that
so important we have a bunch of really
difficult problems that we're facing
over the next few years and politicians
sometimes say why are you spending time
on on this issue it's an arcane insider
issue but if you think about the
problems that we're trying to solve the
internet isn't the problem the internet
is the solution so just think about the
fact that no matter what we're going to
go through a period of dislocation as
the economy evolves into this more
modern on this more modern platform and
people who are in their 40s are going to
have to rethink you know how they're
making a living they're probably going
to have to be more depend on themselves
there are going to have to find ways of
retraining themselves the way to do that
is to use the internet to make it
possible if the idea of retraining
workers is done as a part of a
government service through a government
institution in the old industrial
hierarchical bureaucratic model of
delivering those services it's going to
be phenomenally expensive what we're
seeing on the internet is really nifty
education startups where peers are
teaching peers how to do things the cost
of that is a tiny fraction of the cost
of the old industrial model of producing
these services so we need this medium to
get us through these really intractable
problems so it's not just a little you
know inside baseball argument between
two rich kids you know it is it is a
threat to the foundation of the internet
which in turn is a
threat to the innovation that we need to
dig ourselves out of these is these
really difficult problems